[Aplausos]
então o julgamento quando falo do meu
chamado integração e com a tranqüila
todos os dias com duas situações de lado
a primeira quando incluído com sistemas
autônomos guerra/ferramenta as pessoas
perguntam se eu trabalho com drones e eu
tenho que esclarecer canal e que
trabalham com sistemas que vem no
momento da identificação a seleção a
iluminação do alvo militar é feita por
uma máquina por um computador sem
qualquer intervenção humana portanto
como estava o drone pendón piloto está
numa consola noitada mil quilômetros de
distância mas que tomar a decisão
puxar o gatilho e portanto a pessoa que
é morta o alvo militar que eliminar
depende exclusivamente de uma decisão
humana e olímpico com os sistemas
autônomos titã cuja programação permite
que não haja nenhum
o segundo fator arma e quando eu digo
não me lamentar mas só vamos saber o
padrão em reação é os padres anos na
promessa e agora vamos administrar
diversos minha no meu objetivo não é
tanto é que depois da experiência
traumática ter sido maquiar outubro é o
pacífico
isso realmente temos duas reações
relativamente isto é as reações são os
tomava c e eu pensar que vou ter um robô
tipo terminar e terá de se virar minha
viva ou morta gente contest for a nossa
criação é completamente dizer não quero
escutar nada pré são todos malucos
pensarmos que podemos vir a ter robôs
humanistas neste caso o vovô vários
africanos também temos pensado no robô
que leva medicamentos água ou comida a
populações cercados por tropas inimigas
se está a passar em alepo na síria
então é o discurso começado será estava
em os que matam não que ajudam sim a e
começamos a ter opiniões completamentos
tramava e eu a minha casa minha vida que
quando foi convidado em londres aqui pra
falar não tá
dizer a minha posição sobre esta matéria
mas e mais chamados a pensar um pouco
mais certa evento é o futuro já é muito
mas eu já trabalho com elas nos estados
unidos reino unido e empregam é só vamos
tratar com os ingleses por trabalhando
pelo ministério da defesa inglês mostrar
a tecnologia inglesa e também no campo
dos androids não público
dispensas que faz com os alunos
provindos do dever de confidencialidade
quando vão mostrar maquete nas próprias
ver o que faz a nível do laboratório já
utilizado no tanque de guerra como por
exemplo a copa com l a lateral eo
progresso é sempre uma uma sogra não é e
nunca saí não tem só gramas tem
rendimento superior a 70 relação a mesma
coisa que não só estava em quando é que
elas frias e de terem namorado não é
esposa mãe quando conhece namorava
namorada de sentar ela é ótima off mexe
trote nós o progresso dizer chega tudo
ótimo mas no meu tempo é que era quando
escrevemos a tentar implementar muito
melhor eo progresso nomeadamente o do
progresso militar sempre provocou este
por orteman em ofuscando o ar que a
flecha por quando foi introduzido nos
500 segue com treinos no campo de
batalha
o papa não cessa na europa tenha muita
influência essas matérias diz nem pensar
matemática que curiosamente está a
voltar com os pilotos de jones que era
nem pensar que um soldado da estiver as
consequências daquilo que produz no
campo de batalha por tanto tempo você
estar frente a frente
perceber que se eu puxo gatilho da arma
fora
a outra pessoa que mora do outro lado
ora é claro ou a proibição tarde e não
durou muito tempo para imaginar mas
depois da primeira guerra mundial
o anjo antes da primeira guerra mundial
os anos na lom berto senão exército
francês disse que essa história da
aviação civil era uma meta que é
conquistar crianças brincarem mac nunca
teria lugar no campo da batalha agora
imaginem o que seria o gol os conflitos
mundiais sem ajuda da inteligência é
aérea tanto progresso tempo estreou esta
atitude reservados nossa voz privada
nunca sugeriam que a internet verso
puder tenha iona me lembro quando tipo
meu primeiro em maio tá
e depois o único o primeiro do fator
cajé do par com os alunos não querem
morrer reacionários da faculdade de
direito é maciço do direito
internacional humanitário que é
basicamente só pra esclarecer é nós nos
preocupamos porque vamos para a guerra
tanto que aos nos cartuns sobre quem vai
à guerra e não me preocupo com isso
preocupa uma vez que um conflito
internacional foi iniciado como é que eu
vou fazer é registar um entre dois
princípios é pimenta taconic from tabu é
incentivar militar os estados de
atacarem e fazer valer as suas posições
e por outro lado aquilo que nós chamamos
o princípio da humanidade que é a
proteção da população civil a população
civil está incluído evidente - hospitais
epe também os próprios edifícios anos
chávez produzida e temos esta atitude de
cumprir o contrato internacional em
geral é uma da talha entre as políticas
com os estados unidos à consciência à
terra mas alguns fazem aquilo que quiser
a droga mas eu pergunto nesta sala que
se a economia americana espirrar qual é
a consequência da tuberculose e se
tivermos uma diretiva comunitária talvez
não afetará a manhã mas nós vamos
arrastar não é só o direito
internacional que é uma adorável mas é
toda a nossa vida melhorada e absoluta
do mais forte do mais fraco da guerra
nota 6 forma particular mas curiosamente
da atração humanitário tem sido e
particularmente eficaz na regulamentação
do armamento e do deste lado acho que é
o guarda costas e outro lado direito
está em os blind invasões foram
utilizados nos anos 80 os estados unidos
a única norte americano é que eu vou
utilizar aqui foi absolutamente bonita
ea proibida os estados de utilizar que
não estava ninguém estudava qualquer
pessoa que encontrasse pela frente e foi
proibida por um protocolo uma convenção
e portanto nenhum estado do turismo
nós também temos o direito na oea e
sentença do tribunal em portugal
significa que existem criminosos
portanto fato do direito internacional
este é também um status que gostamos
violados
do outro lado temos os drones desta um
grande passo pois os nomes também são
sugestivos como podem imaginar e que tem
este aqui é dos mais avançados vai ser
o governo britânico no implícito nos
próximos conflitos a partir de 2018 que
está em uma missão instalado nesse caso
a dupla boca é portanto tem um prémio
estão missa é o que tem já a autonomia
pois vamos ter mais ofertas de ver se
vai atacar ou não ele pode fazer uma
suspensão no ar esperar que o álbum está
no momento exato é que eu possa atacar
qual é o objetivo é que nenhum civil
sata cabo quando por exemplo um turista
tem aqui diz a perceber qual é o
problema das drogas e os problemas dos
dons eco pilotar na sua consola não está
nos estados unidos
mata durante seis horas do dia após seis
horas vai para casa com sua família em
jantar e depois no dia seguinte foi
graças à sua vida lucrativa para
populações com uma paquistão iêmen
somália onde os drones ainda serão
utilizadas as populações locados
apesar de não verem jônicas ao verem um
drone potência máxima como estas
cobriria toda a zona de portugal
continental e ilhas incluídas ao ponto
que poderia registar a nossa conversa
neste momento tanto o que acontece é
entendimento quando um drone fazem o
início de um ataque armado as populações
locais habituar aos que há um
deslocamento de uma onda de calor súbita
imagina quando nós abrimos um fórum
dentro de casa que a temperatura máxima
a nossa lar área e sai que o bafo campo
e tanto as populações começaram a
perceber a entrada dos novos próprio
lado e não queremos que isso aconteça
por um lado do outro lado os pilotos do
trono ao contrário do que possam
imaginar
já e tem vindo a desenvolver síndrome os
traumáticos o psd vê muito mais
acelerados com soldados no terreno
porque porque tem eu geralmente iluminar
um turista com o ataque do drone e
significa controlar a terra vigiá-lo
turano quem vias há três semanas no
mínimo e é preciso que sejam algo
relativamente fácil classificar
significa que o piloto drone ver este
homem é negociar em armas e droga o que
for ou preparar um ataque terrorista
numa estação de metro
nós todos estamos a matar pessoas mas
todos nós não temos
envolvidos nos ataques terroristas
escalar a nossa vez lá está vendo essa
meta e no reino unido como estava em
atendimento lado matar
estamos atrás por meio de download mas
estamos em alerta máxima trabalha e
portanto estou nas últimas três semanas
desmantelaram os ataques sérios com seus
dados e menos sete em inglês aeroportos
centrais longe até é ameaça e assumir as
pessoas que estão envolvidas
ora o que acontece então estamos família
dos meus olhos tanto o nome começa a ser
uma arma muito grande das populações
começam a perceber e mais mesmo quando
há um jogo se eu estiver me iluminar até
mim sobre isso aqui é um jogo que nos
deve fazer 17 falaram os temas mais
agradáveis e provavelmente o senhor
também teriam que votar seria uma
chatice então o pessoal está à venda dos
meus olhos que é o bruno pedron que tem
tem que ser ampliada em 100 vezes
preocupação ver se tiver aqui neste
momento eu não vou fazer as crianças
tanto ninguém está aqui chá mas o joão
segue o princípio da avaliação que está
a chamada ruby drowning é entendendo
desta forma evitar o mosquito tem dois
princípios primários segue uma
tecnologia bauru do boston o que
significa em termos lagos fica que não é
programado mas quem é tenta voar com 17
é colocado num laboratório e com
introduzir um mecanismo que permita a
prender um skate como é que levanta vôo
e como é que evita os tacos depois na
sua ponta tem mas trinca como podem ver
e que geralmente quando nós temos que
eliminar uma pessoa que nos ganhar se a
tua ligava para o serviço secreto há
placas a pessoa atrás da orelha da casa
pessoa tenha que fazer assim porque
santa picada não destrua o drone
o drone enfia uma piscadela tal paulo
espigão da velha depois é entendendo e
depois em função da classificação que
fazemos da pessoa em causa pode ser o
mesmo para ficar quero uma taquicardia
quer câmeras câmeras súbitas nas pernas
mobilização da parte central e que
depois vende atualmente a pessoa sente
se mal e entra uma equipe para médicos
que curiosamente não demora mais que um
minuto
uma estação metros e depois quando usar
só a um centro hospitalar particular o
próprio e portanto a tecnologia tem
vindo a ser cada vez mais conduzida mais
precisa
qual é o nosso problema que temos com
essas drogas é um problema se temos uma
amostra de cabelo papel é é a ampla
pesquisa de mercado e migra com os
termos nem inglês mas o quanto temos uma
amostra do hotel o cabelo tanto mais uma
amostra da vnn portanto a eficiência do
sistema é quase perfeita
se temos por exemplo que ocorrer a roupa
e chay do zé traíra é a uma taxa que
posso e variados 20 por cento de ferro
que no caso das situações de estações de
metro
outros aeroportos e torna se
particularmente complicada do projeto é
que eu não posso utilizava os alunos
poderão ver gera na nossa universidade e
fazemos o que está planificado aqui
também um livro só as consequências
jurídicas estão aqui falar do tratamento
que a robótica faz hoje em dia e temos
esta gravura o o menor portanto uma nova
base que nós fazemos estudos do peito
pra cima em que estudamos um aluno
durante 72 horas com sensores ligados à
toda parte da cia' fazemos o aluno
mulher rir chuvarada do tipo movimentos
porque os sensores vão estudar como é
que as nossas expressões faciais se
movimentam na bahia no rio da mesma
forma qualquer outra pessoa nesta sala
depois após esse estudo completo da
etapa em cana que constrói a estrutura
está por trás da indústria dos plásticos
e cria o piloto exames cabelo temos os
alunos são pagos para achar puxa o
cabelo tanto os vê nisso um incentivo
para pagar as propinas e e pois é tentar
fazer uns testes das pessoas é
identificar a quem é o kobo e quem é
woman deste lado tem o professor osmar é
o maior especialista em robótica android
do mundo inteiro e que está no seu robô
lado e quando começa uma confiança
geralmente começa
o e ela parece 15 minutos depois caso
não vai falar no tse na montanha em pó e
e claro as pessoas mandam um salto e
porque já não sabem quem é que stalin
própria vida em outro lado da robótica e
pois temos ainda uma tecnologia que eu
tô ligado ponto de vista das
conseqüências jurídicas que possam
implicar quando temos a tecnologia que
nós chamamos orquestrava ou em inglês
quando temos a tecnologia em suor
o que significa isso significa que vamos
ter por exemplo um exército de sangue
imaginem que está em 100 roriz numa
estação de metro numa estação de
comboios em que preciso eliminar aquelas
100 pessoas não saem duas mil pessoas
naquela estação com borges portanto o
que eu faço é uma orquestra de be
dragons ou os mais sofisticados e tem
aqui um filme baseado em um modelo russo
vai levantar quem mais assustador a
imagem de seu próprio presidente
mas em e portanto todos os temas com zé
não entra se em que nenhum operador
humano consegue sequer ter a velocidade
ou a capacidade de introduzir num
processo de 5 é que juridicamente as
coisas começam a tomar
como podem imaginar muito complicada e
agora vamos aqui ah ah ah basicamente a
minha tese de doutoramento físicas a
iata cartucho e esta o prêmio estão na
versão mais sofisticada a partir daqui
que não posso revelar só por uma questão
de segredo não precisa roubar nas idéias
do tratamento uma nova para comparar
objectivamente mas por questões dos
grandes tabus mas o o o brighton este
modelo mais avançado faz é o piloto
pobre evento identifica juramento alvo
mas pode não ter circunstâncias de
visibilidade
mas nem precisava daquilo que nós
chamamos o usuário guerra por tanto
tempo estado dará etc entretanto não é
possível detectar o alvo que eu quero
bater portanto eu limitaria onde esta
missa vai atuar e este me salvar a
procura dos alvos foram previamente
selecionados pelo piloto itamar mas
minha alma minha autonomia e nós não
estamos num canto a autonomia e então eu
vai a própria mas nem o alvo é o afonso
e portanto meus sonhos
não gosto de iniciados masc assim não
estará na estréia e é ou não é o que é
que faz faz com que está já de forma
isolada entre um senhor seja afetado por
esta explosão e portanto para que eu tô
numa zona com imensos serviço e eu
suspendo no ar é capaz de andar às
voltas e se vir não é tempo capaz para
decidir lá autoestradas para além do
fato é um sistema quase anos por ali 97%
é é imune a ataques cibernéticos
portanto minha porque é um sistema de
códigos em algo do seu lixo simples
nacional que explicar em que permite ao
lançar uma chapa pura ficção que se
qualquer pessoa tentar entrar no sistema
e um autogolo cai o que acontece é que
este sistema já voltou a tentar atacar o
avião que demandava atuar da outra parte
ora isto é tudo muito bonito mas o
problema e nos anos 80 foi quando um
sistema auto não quero saber o que é
postado tô da identificação davos no
estágio tanto um vôo de lhe dar um vôo
comercial com 256 passageiros a bordo
foi identificar pelo sistema conforme se
um alvo militar o próprio sistema tomou
a iniciativa de comunicar a comandar o
futebol
por uma razão que agora não interessa
que explicar o sistema não tem
comunicação não foi pro sava isso tema
automaticamente só um míssil tanto estes
havia um é batido 250 passageiros mais a
tripulação lugar a um processo normal o
problema é quem é o responsável de ter
chave um gatilho cuja decisão nunca foi
humana e aqui é que começa o problema
dos habitats e é como é que eu vou
implantar a responsabilidade e uma arma
cujo processo de identificação na
seleção e precisão dos alvos militares é
feita por uma máquina
ao mesmo tempo e agora com o povão em
outro centro também estouraram o tempo
de mostrar o meu é também ao mesmo tempo
vemos coisas erradas podemos ver a nona
sinfonia de beethoven a ser interpretada
por ons
pensem que os treinos estão programadas
está o primeiro exemplos temos temas
absolutamente autónomos cada dono foi
apenas programar para reagir a uma cova
é uma copa ea função do acorda fase é
fórmulas de sua produção dos algoritmos
que proclamavam não entenderam eu também
não sei estado que estou a dizer por que
sou porque sou do direito e ficará agora
está pronto e agora
também ao
[Música]
space no to
inicialmente eu também choro de um lado
como foi vendido por menos e dispor de
um populismo é meu papel e oito a onze
inicial
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
[Música]
o enterro está abrigado